la arteriosclerosis es una enfermedad
potencialmente mortal que puede comenzar
a desarrollarse durante la niñez esta
enfermedad es un proceso en el que los
depósitos de material graso llamado
placa se acumulan en las paredes de las
arterias reduciendo o bloqueando por
completo el flujo sanguíneo si bien las
causas exactas de la arteriosclerosis no
están claras muchos científicos afirman
que ésta empieza con el daño a la pared
interna de una arteria llamada endotelio
las sustancias transportadas a través de
la sangre como el colesterol las grasas
y los productos de desecho celular se
acumulan en el área dañada de la pared
arterial
las reacciones químicas que se presentan
dentro de la acumulación de material
hacen que las moléculas de colesterol se
oxiden esto da lugar a una respuesta
inflamatoria en la que las células
endoteliales del sitio dañado liberan
sustancias químicas que indican una
llamada de auxilio como respuesta los
monocitos del torrente sanguíneo se
dirigen hacia el sitio bañado el
estímulo del colesterol oxidado
convierte los monocitos en macrófagos
los macrófagos comen y digieren las
moléculas de colesterol como resultado
de este proceso los macrófagos se
convierten en células espumosas las
cuales se acumulan para formar la placa
en la medida en que la placa aumenta de
tamaño la pared arterial se hace más
densa y se endurece
al mismo tiempo las células musculares
lisas dentro de la pared arterial
empiezan a multiplicarse
la mayoría de células musculares lisas
se mueven hacia la superficie de la
placa estas células contribuyen a la
formación de una tapa fibrosa firme que
cubre la placa
finalmente el pasillo a través de la
arteria se estrecha lo suficiente como
para reducir el flujo sanguíneo y la
cantidad de oxígeno recibida por los
órganos que abastece con el tiempo la
etapa puede erosionar y abrirse
liberando placas en el torrente
sanguíneo la placa puede fluir y
contribuir a la formación de un coágulo
de sangre que puede detener el flujo
sanguíneo como resultado un suministro
limitado de sangre está disponible en
las áreas alrededor de la arteria
parcialmente bloqueada degradando y
potencialmente matando al tejido vecino